Even if there's a minority of
good in a place that isn't good,
it won't be slated for destruction.
That's kind of a good thing.
And the third is a minority of good in a
place can keep it from being destroyed.
And that's a really good thing too.
And I believe that as well.
I think that good is
more powerful than evil.
Naivety isn't.
But I think that good is,
and I think that in a
place that's corrupt,
a minority of people who stand forth
against the corruption can prevail.
Now,
you know,
I think,
I think one of the best
examples of that again,
was all Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn because
he was in the terrible work camps when he
wrote his book.
He memorized most of it,
which is not an easy thing to do when
it's 2100 pages long and set in very tiny
font.
And he memorized most of it.
And then he wrote it and it was one of
the things that brought down the Soviet
Union.
You know,
it was published in the 1970s
first of all in Wa in the West.
And the first thing that happened,
at least initially was that
the
communism as an ethical
system lost absolutely all
credibility whatsoever among
anyone who is even vaguely educated.
Immediately upon the publication
of the Gulag archipelago,
he pulled the moral slots
out from underneath it.
And the book was definitely one
of the reasons there were many,
but was definitely one of the reasons
why the rotten system crumbled and fell
without a war.
And that's a great example of how one
person can take on a tyranny and prevail.
So,
and he's not the only person
who did that sort of thing.
Cause what Gandhi did the same thing.
I mean,
I don't think the English
were the Russians,
but you know,
things were not so good in India.
And what Gandhi did in India under the
influence by the way of Leo Tolstoy,
um,
was also a remarkable example of a single
person intervening in a catastrophe
and,
and setting it far more
right than it could be.